Ngay mục sau thằng sau, công an tình hương in phối hợp với cuộc an ninh mạng và phòng trống tối phạm sử dụng công nghệ cao,
bộ công an, chịt phá thình công đường dây đánh bạng.
Dự tin và trình bá văn hóa phẩm đôi trị qua mạng, số tin sau dịch lên tới 1 in 2,3 tỡ đồng.
Mới năm đối tượng bị bắt sử tưởng chú tại các tình hương in, hại dương, đặc lắc và thành phố Hà Nội.
Câm đầu đều hành đường dây là phạm chi chúng, xin năm 1 in, chiến trăm chiến miếm ba, Hà Nội.
Lối tượng phủ chắc viết của quay phay thống chung ra thành phẩm và quay phay phay sách sách là hoàng ít phyên, xin năm 1 in, chiến trăm chiến miếm.
Đặc lắc, tại thời điểm bắt sử, hệ thống này đặc sử lý hằng chục nghiên thể cao viến thông,
trên đổi thành điểm ảo để đánh bạng, đồng thời lên kết với các đại lý hỏa đổ theo 1 in đặc gấp.
Dưới ổ máy tính thì hiện nhau đối tượng quan trị, vẫn hành 1 trong 2 mi tượng quay phay sách sách có gắn bên nơi,
và hỏng cáo cho các trang đánh bạc có chứ nổi dùng giâm ổ, hư giâm, đổi truy.
Các đổi tượng sự dụng công nghệ cao để chân dấu hành vi, thường xin thay đổi tên biên,
sự dụng IP giả và giác bằng tiền kiết thật số USD tên nhằm dự tiền.
Các quan đều tra đặc hệ tổ vụ án, khởi tổ bị cân, tiếp tục mở dụng đều tra,
làm gió vài trò của các đổi tượng liên quan.